jetzt wird eklig oh mein Gott ihr kennt
doch bestimmt diese gartenhack Videos
die immer Millionen von aufrufen
bekommen und wo man auch denkt
funktioniert das wirklich ich baue jetzt
seit ungefähr zehn Jahren mein eigenes
Gemüse an deswegen würde ich sagen habe
ich so ein bisschen Ahnung was was
angeht und wir schauen jetzt mal rein
und gucken was an diesen Tipps
eigentlich alles dran ist aha das ist
ein Wassermelone Trick da wird also die
wassermelonenfrucht wenn sie kleines in
so eine Form reingehangen und wechseln
in dieser Form das klappt tatsächlich
das habe ich auch schon mal gesehen dass
das bei Gurken klappt also wenn ihr mal
Lust habt herzchengurken zu lernen oder
so dann könnt ihr die Wendy klein sind
in so eine Form eingeben ich würde schon
mal darüber nachdenken ob das vielleicht
pflanzenfellerei ist oder wenn man die
Frucht so ein quetscht und die zwingt in
der bestimmten Form zu wachsen aber es
sieht ziemlich cool aus also das ist
immerhin mal ein Trick der auch
funktioniert aber schauen wir mal wie es
weitergeht ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
das ist so bleibt okay das sieht auch
lustig aus hier haben wir einen Schwamm
in den Samen reingemacht werden dann
kommt
wer der angefeuchteten da kommt zu einem
Glas drauf ich denke mal damit das nicht
verdunstet das Wasser und jetzt wachsen
hier die Pflänzchen raus und ich weiß ja
nicht also ich denke das ist auch wieder
was was funktioniert weil die Samen
ebenso schön von der Feuchtigkeit
umgeben sind und erstmal nicht so
schnell austrocknen weil die bilden ja
wenn sie ihre Blätter ausbilden auch
gleichzeitig Wurzeln und die Wurzeln
Wurzeln dann in den ganzen Schwamm rein
und dann muss man das irgendwie so da
raus friemeln und hat am Ende entweder
kaputte Wurzeln von seinen Plätzchen
oder irgendwelche Stücke von diesem
schwamm in seiner Erde das will man ja
glaube ich beides nicht deswegen ja es
gibt sehr sehr viel bessere
Möglichkeiten Samen vor zu keinem als so
einen Schwamm hier zu benutzen ich habe
eklig hier haben wir so ein Katzenklo
ist die Katze hat die da rein gemacht
[Applaus]
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die
Konstruktion mit der ich meine Micro
Greens in der Küche züchte also ich
glaube das funktioniert aber mir ist
immer noch nicht ganz klar der ist
katzenkacker mit drin ist vielleicht als
Dünger vielleicht brauchen die noch
irgendwie mehr Halt dieser also bei mir
habe ich da so eine kleine Matte drin
das Krepppapier oder so also ich würde
sagen das könnte funktionieren und ich
weiß was Katzen total auf dieses Zeug
abfahren okay hier ist so ein Teil mit
dem man so Pflanzlöcher in die Erde
machen kann ne und dann kommt deine
Pflanze rein aber nur so ein zwei das
ergibt jetzt erstmal gar keinen Sinn
warum man dafür so ein riesen Loch
machen muss also das ist wieder so eine
Frage von klar kann man das machen aber
warum sollte irgendwer so Blödsinn
machen jetzt rücken die die Pflanze auch
noch zurecht also ja klassischer
ah hier ist mein Plastikflaschen Trick
man kann mit Plastikflaschen ziemlich
coole Sachen machen mal gucken was hier
jetzt geplant ist wir haben da so ein
Loch rein geschnitten jetzt kommt ein
Stock rein ich habe schon mal sowas
ähnliches gebaut und ich glaube ich weiß
dass die Farben ganz genau die nehmen
das um so nicht vom Baum runter zu
pflücken wenn man nicht so richtig dran
kommt und tatsächlich habe ich genauso
was auch schon mal gebaut das
funktioniert richtig richtig gut auch
wenn das Teil natürlich nicht länger als
eine Saison hält wenn man Glück hat
meistens so mussten wir dann auch
irgendwie mal die Flasche ersetzen wenn
die kaputt gegangen ist aber das
funktioniert und so kommt man auch noch
an die Äpfel die oben hängen die sonst
vielleicht vergammeln würden also
eigentlich ein sehr cooler Trick jetzt
geht's um Grünlilien damit eine
Haarnadel genommen und dann werden die
so fixiert um die weiter zu vermehren
die kann man ja so gut über Ableger
vermehren übrigens falls da draußen
Leute sind die Lust haben Gemüse
anzubauen aber denken bei mir überlebt
ja noch nicht mal der Kaktus das ist bei
mir ganz genau so also ich kann mich
auch um keine Zimmerpflanze kümmern
außer vielleicht um grünen Lilien also
die verzeihen ja wirklich alles aber
ansonsten geht's den bei mir auch immer
total schlecht und ich liebe es trotzdem
zu gerne also merkt euch das aber zurück
zu diesem Clip das kann man so machen
ich habe das tatsächlich auch schon mal
mit Erdbeeren gemacht also Erdbeeren ja
auch so Ranken Ableger und um die zu
fixieren damit man da eine neue Pflanze
daraus züchten kann kann man das auch
mit paar Nadeln machen ja ist ganz
praktisch aus der ettung oh mein Gott
das ist immer wieder so ein klassischer
Fall von Bullshit und das ist nicht ich
ich rege mich darüber jetzt gerade nicht
so auf weil das ein Tampon ist ne aber
warum sollte man das machen also ich
denke mal hier geht's darum dass die
Frau die Pflanze zu viel gießt und der
Tampon ist er dann das überschüssige
Wasser aufsaugen aber erstmal vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger gießen außerdem hat
der Topf auch unten Löcher damit das
überschüssige Wasser ablaufen kann also
warum muss man das in der Erde aufsaugen
und keine Ahnung es ist doch irgendwie
Verschwendung oder du musst doch gar
keinen Tampon in die Erde stecken ganz
ehrlich ich weiß nicht genau wie die
heißen aber ich glaube Mäuschen Mieter
wo man die Feuchtigkeit in der Erde
messen kann wenn man wissen will ob man
seine Pflanzen zu viel gießt oder nicht
aber man sieht das ja auch daran dass
unten im Übertopf einfach Wasser steht
und bei den allermeisten Pflanzen sollte
da nicht oft Wasser drin stehen weil das
einfach Staunässe für die Pflanze
bedeutet und die das nicht besonders mag
also daran kann man eigentlich schon
ganz gut ablesen ob man seine Pflanze zu
viel gießt oder nicht und das ist
einfach Blödsinn
IG bin gespannt habt ihr das schon mal
ausprobiert irgendwie so eine Avocado
oder so eine Mango in unserem Klima
angebaut hier wird der Same mit
Krepppapier mit feuchtem umwickelt damit
die Feuchtigkeit schön dran bleibt und
das dann in so einem Tütchen reingemacht
damit das Wasser nicht so verdunstet das
mache ich auch sehr sehr gerne alle die
in meinem Kurs Gemüsegarten starten mit
dabei sind wissen dass ich alle
möglichen Samen auf die und ähnliche
andere Arten Vorteile weil das ist super
viele Vorteile hat also gucken wir mal
wie es weitergeht da ist dann der Keim
rausgekommen da schaut jetzt also so ein
langer Keim raus und genau ich denke mal
das Pflanzen die jetzt ein an sich
funktioniert das so das ist auch super
Samen sofort zu keimen aber vielleicht
nicht unbedingt die Samen von Obstbäumen
Obstbäume brauchen super super lange bis
sie zum ersten Mal Früchte tragen und
deswegen aber auch aus anderen Gründen
werden die normalerweise nicht über
Samen vermehrt sondern durch Veredelung
so spart man sich erstens Zeit aber
zweitens erhält man auch die Worte die
man veredelt weil wenn man einen Samen
aus einem Apfel nimmt oder einer Mango
dann heißt das nicht dass die Früchte
die man dann erntet auch so schmecken
wie die Frucht die man hatte aus der man
den Samen genommen hat deswegen ergibt
es einfach viel mehr Sinn Obstbäume
durch veredeln zu vermehren und nicht
über Samen also nicht alles was man im
Internet sieht ist auch so für bare
Münze zu nehmen da drüben verlinke ich
euch ein Video in dem ich schon mal auf
so Garten Hacks aus dem Internet
reagiert habe also schaut da gerne
vorbei ansonsten geht raus und macht die
Welt ein bisschen grüner macht nicht so
viel Blödsinn wie hier in diesem Video
und dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche
wieder mit einem Video macht's gut
[Musik]